dérapage sur la hotline une information
qui concernait les nombreux utilisateurs
d'ordinateurs mais aussi de mobiles
contrairement à leurs promesses les
grands opérateurs téléphoniques et
internet qui s'était engagé pour la fin
2006 à ne plus facturer le temps
d'attentes de leur assistance technique
continue cette pratique coûteuse pour
les consommateurs reportage cyril lebrun
mathieu au jour un problème de connexion
à internet le réflexe appeler le service
clientèle de l'opérateur
les minutes défilent et la tante elle
mais facturé aussi
réponse fausse ce temps d'attentes et
bien facturés et c'est notamment encore
le cas chez free neuf cegetel et
bouygues telecom des minutes décomptées
du forfait téléphonique ou facturé 34
centimes d'euro la minute les opérateurs
internet et téléphonie s'était pourtant
engagé il ya deux ans à rendre ce
service gratuit en 2007 les
retardataires tente de se justifier
jusqu'ici nous avons préféré investir
pour réduire le temps d'attenté clients
et améliorer la qualité du service rendu
par les services clientèle selon eux il
n'y aurait pas d'histoire d'argent
derrière tout cela les appels payants
couvre seulement 25 % du coût total de
notre service clientèle le temps
d'attentes
c'est inférieur à 40 secondes chaillou
représente une faible proportion de la
durée totale de l'appel tous assurent
que dans les semaines à venir le
problème sera réglé les associations de
consommateurs elles réclament carrément
la disparition de ces appels surtaxés il
faut rappeler que 34 centimes d'euro
c'est six à sept fois plus cher que le
prix d'un appel normal depuis un fixe
quelle est la légitimité lorsqu'un
consommateur a été victime d'un problème
de leur facturer sur un appel comme
celui là si les opérateurs ne se met pas
très vite en conformité le gouvernement
menace de légiférer sur la question